what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and I'm back at it again
with a huge chapter to discuss this Arc
is definitely not off to a slow start as
already we got Blackbeard showing up yet
again and wow it's big so make sure to
stay tuned for this one channel parking
with it and smash that like button if
you enjoy seeing these weekly one-piece
reviews and updates and want to keep
them coming make this the video you
subscribe if you haven't already and hit
that notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates and now
without further Ado let's jump into its
spoilers and all this chapter is called
the only family I got and the cover
story is even huge we see Charlotte
cracker a sweet Commander with a 860
million Bounty Frozen and it looks like
pudding has been kidnapped this raises
the possibility that koozan who as we
know has been tied to Blackbeard
defeated cracker with his ice powers and
then kidnap pudding so that Blackbeard
can use her ability to hear the voice of
all things for the pone glyphs this will
seem all the more likely after what
happened happens at the end of this
chapter but just wow so much craziness
in just the cover story people anyways
on to the chapter proper and we got
Bonnie Luffy and Chopper big and
satisfied after all the food from the
machine Chopper bets everyone would love
the food machine except maybe Sanji I
love that comment and yeah it totally
makes sense if a machine can make
delicious food then it kind of makes
sanji's cooking seem less special but
beyond that I'm sure Sanji would also
have philosophical issues with a machine
cooking as well and how a machine could
never attain the same level of artistry
it's then funny on how this Punk
comments on how much they love to eat
and how they all have bulging bellies
now and so she includes jimbei into it
as well even though he hasn't been
picking out like the others he even says
his was already like that I love the
detail how you even have a mechanical
dog that recycles that would definitely
be useful in real life this Punk says
she's gonna get back to work commenting
on if she doesn't run Riot no one will
so clearly we're gonna find out what
that means eventually our group then
sees lab assistants wearing unique
clothes Luffy finds a closed machine and
puts on similar clothing to the lab
assistants commenting that despite the
way they look they're actually nice and
Breezy even the clothing is futuristic
of course Bonnie is very excited for
free clothes and ends up picking a
battle uniform all these machines are
definitely perfect for a mad scientist
who just wants to focus on working all
the time they save you from having to
get food or clothes and you're free to
just do science as much as possible as a
YouTuber it would definitely be nice to
have those as well I gotta say back to
Bonnie the machine undresses and dresses
her despite the fact that she says she
can undress herself and I gotta say she
looks great in the outfit loving having
Bonnie this Arc and the futuristic
cosplay is the cherry on top of the cake
she comments on how the boots are light
and make it feel like she's floating on
the air I love how Jim ends up picking a
Hawaiian shirt that's completely
different from the rest he says the
clothes would have been great for the
disguises although it's probably too
late now Bonnie is about to head off on
her own to find some weapons and deal
with vegapunk but then while still
eating which is a hilarious touch after
they just ate so much already Luffy sees
Kuma wearing a police uniform the police
Kuma pacifista shoots laser beams at
them since they are the provisions and
garment stealing thieves our dudes are
of course shocked that it wasn't free
and the hilarious comment is brought up
how police Kuma is causing huge damage
that has to be worse than what they did
as he is attacking them I like that they
bring that up and we're not just like
bro how is stealing some food a problem
and you can like destroy everything
around Luffy decides that he has to
fight back but then Bonnie stops him
obviously we know why she did it it's
because Kuma is her dad but these guys
don't know that yet accordingly Luffy
gets upset notably though he gets her
name right at least in this translation
when he says what the heck Bonnie that's
huge this is when she reveals to them
that it's her father and begins to cry
the title comes into play here as
everyone is shocked at the news she says
he's the only family she's got she begs
not to hurt her daddy and by this point
she's tearing up big time while we get
an adorable flashback to her as a little
girl playing with human Kuma this panel
definitely has Robin crying and Nami
crying Vibes so could it be
foreshadowing that Luffy will help this
crying girl as well and that she'll
become a member of the crew as well let
me know what you think but the fact that
she doesn't have any family anymore
leaves a void that the nakama could
definitely fill if you ask me and I also
think we could use more girls on the
crew anyways Luffy goes to save her from
what he says is just a pacifista and he
calls her a dummy too obviously they're
going to be fine but we get a
cliffhanger where we see a big explosion
before moving on still it's good to see
all the bonding with Luffy and Bonnie I
must say I'm loving it then we get a
certain C in the new world and we
recognize Blackbeard's unique laugh they
are attacking law and his crew which
we've called out before for being the
most useless crew so far out of his kids
and Luffy's props to Blackbeard who had
no trouble dealing with an underwater
submarine it's said with another hit the
water pressure will crush them so they
decide to surface there's no choice they
got a battle and then we see a female
law and even a female Beppo and I gotta
say the female Beppo is hilarious lost
crew members are even in love talking
about how their Captain is so cute now
see what I'm saying not the most useful
crew right here by the way how crazy
would it be if disability was used on
Zorro and we saw sanji's reaction he'd
be so torn it would be hilarious anyways
they call it an infection and it spreads
to the other crew members as well as
mentioned they're doing the so-called
Forced Gender flipping because
Blackbeard is hoping it will disorient
law and his crew law is sweating so he
is nervous but he says it'll be fine and
his clashes with the Emperors taught him
that that devil fruit powers can be
countered if you use a great deal of
hockey again we have the theme of Hockey
being more important than fruit Powers
which I like otherwise a broken fruit
could lead to a cheap Victory which no
one wants that law succeeds in
nullifying the disease duck Q is the one
that used his six fruit to do it all he
calls that one the Milady transformation
plague and you can bet he has a lot more
of those plagues to come you can
definitely see why he'd be such a threat
to the World At Large and that also I'd
say deserves a huge Bounty then we see
van auger use a warp warp root to
teleport Burgess to the island where law
and his crew are another crazy fruit
power Burgess uses the buff buff fruit
to lift an entire Mountain he even calls
his fruit of the best since super
strength is already a thing with strong
characters you can only imagine how op
this fruit must be it has to amplify
physical strength way more or it
wouldn't even be a fruit thus Burgess
May well be the physically strongest
person in the series right now crazy how
much Oda is showing off the Blackbeard
Pirates here he's really hyping them up
this Arc so I'm hoping that this Arc
will have a consistent Blackbeard Focus
live in comments on how these guys have
hunted down some insane powers and how
it's no wonder their bounties keep
Rising keep that in mind their bounties
keep Rising we'll come back to that the
mountain is going to crush them when law
activates room Blackbeard makes his
appearance and he's riding on stronger
who has the mythical Zone Pegasus fruit
another mythical Zone to add to the list
and of course Blackbeard will have
another one on his crew keep in mind
even though stronger is sort of a Joe
character too getting tired and stuff
pretty easily you can bet that there
will be more crazy abilities that come
with a mythical Zone than just flying
Blackbeard reveals that he knew when law
kid and Luffy left wano one of them
would end up here but he had no way of
knowing who that's an interesting
comment and it means Blackbeard could
have potentially already run into Luffy
but of course this works better so Oda
can keep building up their rivalry and
hyping up their eventual battle
Blackbeard comments with big mom and
kaido gone the world's gonna turn on its
head and he says that sounds fun I
absolutely love that response again
makes you think of the cover story and
how Blackbeard would want to take
advantage of their absence by hunting
down their valuable assets Blackbeard
makes it clear that he's after the road
pornoglyphs and the rubbings that law
has including kaido's law says the same
right back wanting any that Blackbeard
has we're told when Titans Clash
suggesting we are going to get a crazy
battle next chapter or at least at some
point between these two legends the
harsh reality is though no matter how
much you like law law and his crew are
absolutely no match for yonko Blackbeard
and his crew and keep in mind Blackbeard
had a bounty close to shanks's before he
attacked boa then he went on to kidnap
Kobe the Marine hero potentially kidnap
pudding with kuzan's help and now he's
about to beat slash kidnap law and
potentially get immortality remember
that that was one of the opeopenomi's
abilities that the current user could
sacrifice their life to Grant another
Eternal youth or life we're not totally
clear on how this will look yet but it
was mentioned before in the story so
chances are it will come into play
obviously Blackbeard would love this but
I also find it very hard to believe that
Oda would sacrifice law a very popular
character we'll see what happens but
Blackbeard in a sense as I'll explain
has definitely surpassed Shanks with
this I wouldn't go so far as to say that
Blackbeard has definitely surpassed
Shanks strength wise or that he could
beat him in a one-on-one fight because
Shanks has just been all flexing so far
but Bounty wise after the bowl attack
the Kobe kidnapping and now inevitably
taking down a dude with a bounty as high
as yonko Luffy's he will have to
Skyrocket especially if as lost says
their bounties are always going up
already I gotta say I was not expecting
such a good crazy chapter but I'm so
glad Oda over delivered here I was
thinking maybe we just get some
continuing events on Egghead but this
Blackbeard Insanity was amazing
especially since Blackbeard is like one
of my favorite antagonists ever so
getting such a hype chapter with him in
it was amazing definitely smash that
like button if you love this chapter
like me let me know your theories for
what will happen does anyone actually
think that law has a chance let me know
in the comments law can use his
Awakening but that makes me also wonder
what would Blackbeard's Awakening be has
he already awakened it or are we gonna
see something else crazy from his
awakened devil fruits so much to get
hyped about with this Cliffhanger make
this the video you subscribe if you
haven't already and hit that
notification Bell so you don't miss
future one piece videos and updates
while you wait for the next chapter to
drop feel free to check out my one piece
playlist that includes videos and all
the Admirals yonko an hour long video
about Shanks and much more link to that
is in the description on screen right
now thanks for watching and until next
time see you Space Cowboys